and gentlemen
the following resolution was adopted by
the world tourist Association sport of
directors
whereas
the world tourist Association is a
non-governmental organization with
special consultative status at the
United Nations economic and social
Council
it provides a unique free and open forum
for the international judicial Community
where judges lawyers law professors law
students and legal professionals from
around the world
can work cooperatively to promote
strengthened and expand the rule of law
and its institutions
throughout all the nations of the world
a world ruled by law not force
has been the world's tourist
associations
model since 60 years since its
foundation in 1963.
through events such as this world law
Congress the
associations continues to build on its
foundation
calling for a system of laws that will
ensure peace and equality without the
use of force and advocating for values
such as human dignity and equality
whereas
the rule of law is the only alternative
to the rule of force only through the
rule of law can human beings live in
Peace and Freedom
the world tourist Association has over
the years granted Awards to those who
have strengthened and protected the rule
of law
among them
Winston Churchill Rene Casa Nelson
Mandela his majesty the king of Spain
Ruth's father Ginsburg Andrew Young and
the Colombian people led by their
president Ivan Duque
whereas
the values of the world tourist
Association are reflected in the
successful process of European
integration based on the rule of law as
a guarantor of the Dignity of every
person
the European integration is an example
of how over so many decades the rule of
law contributes to achieving decisive
advances for Humanity according to the
motto of the world tourist Association
peace through law
whereas
the EU is above all an institution based
on the respect for the laws container
marital rights which are in turn based
on the international legal documents
such as universal Declaration of Human
Rights a binding part of the Aki
commuter
the European Union and the European
commission acting as guardian of the
treaties ensure that member states and
their citizens comply with the rule of
law
whereas
As We Gather here at the United Nations
Headquarters on 21st of July 2023
the world tourist association takes
another step in upholding the legacy of
the association founders
this year it grants its highest award
that many consider to be the Nobel Prize
in law
the world's peace and Liberty award
to the European Commission
represented by its president Ursula from
The Life
[Applause]
thank you Vivian it is now my high
privilege to call to the podium his
Excellency Justin Trudeau prime minister
of Canada for the ladacio for the
European Commission
[Applause]
good morning dear friends again by
thanking the world law Congress and
Javier cremades for today's event
I want to acknowledge his majesty King
Philippe VI of Spain president lasso and
all the dignitaries gathered here and of
course and especially my dear friend
Ursula vandelion we're all gathered to
honor today along with the European
Union
is that me mercy
friends thank you for meeting today
80 years ago we laid down our weapons
after the deadliest war humankind had
ever seen
the second world war left Europe in
ruins it sent millions of people to
their graves people from all over the
world including tens of thousands of
Canadians
and it forced a reckoning
for centuries Europe had been Riven with
conflict the continent's history marked
by endless rivalries and individual
Ambitions that led to bloody contests
over land over language over resources
I should know Canada was a direct
byproduct of all of those
but by the middle of the 20th century
leaders understood that the Machinery of
War had become too dangerous to allow to
continue this way
so From the Ashes of the second World
War
the European commission was born
it was created by those who believed
that if we tied our Fates together
through shared prosperity and Collective
growth
if we respected the rights freedoms
languages and cultures of others in
return for their respect of Our Own
if we transcended the destabilizing
forces of our individual interests
and United ourselves in a community of
values grounded in the rule of law
if we did that
we could overcome the brutal antagonism
that had entrenched the continent for
centuries and build a lasting peace
it was a Triumph of imagination over
history
the European commission has become a key
institution that plays a central role on
the global scale
together the members of the European
commission represent the third largest
world economy and bring together more
than half a billion people speaking 24
languages living in 27 different
countries countries who practice a
myriad of different religions and come
from all corners of the globe
processes institutions and Democratic
Values at the core of the European
commission have enabled peace and
prosperity to Prevail in Europe over
second seven decades now
this is the accomplishment we honor and
award the European commission with today
and
to accept the award as my friend Ursula
from The Lion president of the European
Commission
I've worked alongside Ursula for almost
four years now I can tell you that she
personally embodies the very best values
of the European Commission she is
principled
she is compassionate
she is formidable
and she drives outcomes
through respect and consensus
Canada I suspect was chosen today to
speak to European success
in part because yes our own history was
shaped by the historical power struggles
I mentioned earlier
but also because I think we too
understand that in this day and age
differences and diversity
can be made into a source of strength
and resilience
not a source of weakness
president fundalian took her role at a
time of uncertainty around the future of
Europe
brexit left many wondering if the union
would continue to hold strong
Euro skepticism was on the rise and
protectionism and authoritarianism were
becoming more prevalent
of course this populism was not just
European excessive nationalism was
breaking through around the world
threatening the principles of collective
prosperity
as choruses like America first got
louder
both Canada and Europe felt held fast to
our belief that growth doesn't come from
putting up walls or turning inwards
which is why we were able to sign an
incredibly ambitious trade deal together
against a backdrop of protectionism and
insular thinking
Canada and Europe both understand that
we are at our best
when we are all doing better
we have faced crisis after crisis that
has proven this
just a few months after Ursula took
office as president the pandemic hit
and her steady leadership made a real
difference for Europe
but also for Canada and for the world
as a medical doctor and as a mother of
seven Ursula understood that we would
only get through it if we got through it
together
we had many many conversations during
that time and she always emphasized that
true resilience is only assured when we
remain not just United by our values
but that we act on them
and that principle is at the very core
of the European Commission
what underpins everything Europe and
Canada stand for
and our democracies around the world
is the rule of law
Ursula is called the rule of law
essential for the protection of the
values on which our Union is founded
democracy Freedom equality
and respect for human rights
this place we're in today the United
Nations is one of the other great peace
building institutions to rise from the
ruins of the second World War
and its foundational document is the UN
Charter
193 countries are party to this Charter
and it is one of the key instruments of
international law
upholding and abiding by this Charter is
what has led to unprecedented peace
stability and prosperity around the
world
which makes what Vladimir Putin is
trying to do a problem for everyone
everywhere
the brutal unprovoked invasion of
Ukraine by Putin is another attempt to
impose the law of the strongest and if
it succeeds everybody will suffer that's
why Canada the EU and many of our
friends and allies will always be there
for Ukraine
equivocally strong supporter of Ukraine
as we may live across the globe but we
must advocate for them at all
multilateral tables where each of us
have a voice
particularly with emerging economies
Ursula
has been absolutely unwavering in her
own advocacy for Ukraine and for the
rule of law
in a European context that is complex
in a time of energy crisis and inflation
it's all the more difficult to hold
political consensus
Ursula has been an incredibly effective
leader
she has galvanized European support
militarily financially and politically
for Ukraine's defense
and she has helped ensure that the
Democratic World remains steadfastly
behind Ukraine
and behind the principles for which it
is fighting
sovereignty
territorial integrity
the rule of law
and the right of people to choose their
own future
she was one of the first foreign leaders
to visit the country after the invasion
began
she witnessed the atrocities in fucha
firsthand
when there were still body bags in the
streets
she understands the scale of the
humanitarian crisis and demonstrated her
compassion when in those early weeks of
the invasion she brought the world
together to provide refuge and support
to the millions of people fleeing
Putin's bombs
I was in grief last month where I
dressed the verco of Narada I spoke of
how Ukraine is the tip of the spear that
is determining the future of the 21st
Century
as a sovereign United Nation we must
support Ukraine in its fight regardless
of what it must cost and however long it
lasts authoritarianism win
we must ensure that borders mean
something
that might
never becomes right
that the Ambitions and desires of one
entity or of one individual do not Stamp
Out the rights of others
the German writer Thomas Mann described
democracy as being built on respect for
the infinite dignity
of each individual
we cannot take democracy for granted
the European commission has shown that
when we overcome our differences when we
embrace them and Forge consensus that
is the most powerful driver
Solutions in the world
and this is important because the future
holds other enormous challenges
it is the principles and values that we
are celebrating together that will allow
us to tackle climate change and to
protect people from the worst
consequences thereof Plains leadership
Europe has laid a path to being Net Zero
by 2050. and many European nations have
accelerated their work to meet this
target as they've moved away from
Russian fossil fuels towards clean
energy
in Canada of course is ready to be your
partner in this work from Germany
investing in Canadian hydrogen to
Romania drawing on Canadian nuclear
energy expertise and solutions among
many others
in this highly uncertain moment we must
remember that security policy
is climate policy is economic policy is
social policy
the stability of the rules-based
international order calls on us to
unwind our dependence on Commodities
weaponized by authoritarian States as we
protect the resilience of our economies
from their whims
which means standing up to bullies and
protecting those who are suffering the
most while ensuring our middle class is
strong and inequality does not take hold
this
is a consequential moment
and it calls for thoughtful leadership
and strong institutions
and I cannot think of a better
embodiment of those
the nursery and the European commission
you show us how respect for the Dignity
of all leads to the strength to protect
peace no matter what
and this is what we honor today
thank you very much dear friends
thank you Excellency
um uh may I call forward please King
Felipe your majesty and president
cremates
foreign
[Applause]
please welcome
Ursula vandaladen as she receives on
behalf of the European commission the
world peace and Liberty award
[Applause]
and I asked Vivian reading and The
Honorable Henry Molina president of the
Supreme Court of the Dominican Republic
pleased to join as well for a photo
[Applause]
thank you ladies and gentlemen Mrs
Ursula vanderladen
[Applause]
foreign
Dear Justin
my friend thank you so much for your
words
Dr Javier cremares
my dearest Vivian reading
excellencies distinguished guests ladies
and gentlemen
what an honor
to receive this award on behalf of the
European Commission
and this on the occasion of the 60th
anniversary
of the world jurist Association
a network of tourists that would defend
fundamental rights and the rule of law
across the world
as a contribution to Global Peace
60 years on
you are still faithful
to your foundation and your principles
and I want to thank the world's tourist
Foundation Association not only for this
recognition but for your enduring
service for all to all Humanity
peace through the rule of law
this is also the story of a United
Europe
when World War II ended
Europe was in ruin and Ashes
and European countries mortal enemies
five of them decided to forgive
not forget
but forgive
they stretched out their hand to Germany
and others
and over time invited them back into the
circle of democracies
under one condition
to do everything necessary
for just and Lasting peace grounded on
the rule of law
my father was 15 years old when World
War II ended
his generation had grown up in Germany
surrounded by lawlessness
devastation
and the negation of human dignity
his country has brought death and
destruction to the whole world
around him was only shame and despair
and then the European idea was born
he was overwhelmed by the power of
reconciliation and the rule of law
in 1957 he witnessed the foundation of
the European economic Community the
beginning of the European Union
with only six member states at that time
he dedicated his whole life to serving
the European idea
and when he passed in 2014
the European Union had grown to 28
member states
the story of our Union is one of
democracy's young and old
getting stronger together
it is the story of Germany's and Italy's
rebirth after the war
it is the story of Spain's portugals and
Greece's path from dictatorship to
democracy
it is the story of democratic
Renaissance
after the fall of the Iron Curtain
and the next chapter in this story is
being written today
in Ukraine Moldova
Georgia
as well as the Western Balkan
this is Europe's promise
a United continent
where all are equal before the law
with freedom
and democracy
for all
but what does it mean for today's
Europeans
to build peace through the rule of law
what is Europe's mission in this new and
turbulent era in the history of the
world
this is the question I would like to
share some thoughts with you today
the first part of the answer
still has to do with the United Nations
Charter and Global Peace
Vladimir Putin has brought War back to
the European Union and the European
continent
not only
only committing and speakable crimes
with cities raised to the ground
children taken from their families
civilians killed in Cold Blood
this war goes also against the very
foundation of the United Nations Charter
it is targeting the very idea of a world
order based on the international law
where all Sovereign countries have equal
rights
and all countries shall refrain from the
use of force against the territorial
Integrity of political independence of
any state
these are the words of the UN Charter
shall refrain
from the use of force
against the territorial integrity
or political independence of any state
this is why Europe stands by Ukraine for
as long as it takes
Ukraine is not only fighting for its own
freedom
Ukraine is fighting for the freedom of
every country
because this is the principle
of the United Nations Charter
no one wants peace more than the people
of Ukraine
but lasting peace
can only be built upon the foundation of
international law
an independent Ukraine
within its recognized International
borders
where accountability for war crimes has
been met
and with security guarantees so that
ukrainians can be free from Fear
this is at the heart of President
zielinski's peace formula
each of his ten points is based on the
UN Charter and U.N resolutions
the charter must be the starting point
for any negotiation for just and Lasting
peace
there's another reason
why this war shows the Deep connection
between peace and the rule of law
ukrainians have made a clear choice
for the rule of law and democracy
they want to join the European Union
and that means deep and structural
reforms
ranging from the independence of the
Judiciary
to anti-corruption
from Minority Rights
to Media freedom
I must say it is amazing to see how fast
and determined Ukraine is implementing
these reforms despite the war
they are defending their country and
reforming
this leads me to my second point
Europe's mission to protect and promote
fundamental rights in an ever-changing
world
our Union was born as an economic
community
then step by step
our free trade area has evolved into a
community of values
and we cast our values into treaties
that protect all people
and bind all countries in our Union
but our job is not done
it is not enough to write down the
promise of equal rights
for all human beings
we must also live up to it every single
day
democracy is a constant work in progress
and our constitutional values must
constantly be translated into action
and guaranteed by the law
let me mention three examples
first
think about the equality between men and
women
it was already spelled out in clear
terms
in the Universal declaration right after
World War II
but what was the meaning of equality for
the post-war generation
it meant freedom to study
and to work
freedom from violence in the streets and
at home
freedom to marry whomever you love
all of this still holds true today
but gender equality means so much more
it is a right to be a mother and to have
a career
it is work-life balance and equal pay
for equal work
it is opportunity to become a doctor or
a judge a soccer player or president of
the European Commission
it is the power to reach for the top and
be anything
you want to be in life
you're probably
familiar
with a quote by Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg
who received this award in 2020 with
just months before she passed
she used to say
that the beautiful words of the U.S
Constitution
We the People
sounded very different in 1787.
back then they only referred to white
men with property
but then little by little
We the People
has become a more inclusive term
and her goal was to keep fighting and I
quote
Until We the People covers everyone who
dwells in this Fair land
of quote
this is Europe's Promise Too
a union of equal rights
for all the people of Europe
my second example there is a new
frontier of fundamental rights and it is
the digital space
it is a new world
where rules don't always apply
automatically
think about children's rights
or consumer protection
but think also about artificial
intelligence
its potential benefits are immense
but it can be harmful for example if it
is used to hire and fire employees
or to monitor citizens through facial
recognition
we need new laws to bring our Eternal
values
in the online world
and Europe has been leading the way
we have been the first in the world to
set rules for digital platforms
and now we are doing the same with
artificial intelligence
this means that all companies that want
to work on our Market must comply with
very high standards
standards that put individuals and their
rights at the center
and at the same time we're working with
like-minded friends like Canada
and the United States but also Japan
Latin American countries
and India
to develop equivalent rules
so that technology enhances individual
freedom
not the state's ability to control us
third and final example
the European Union's founding treaties
promise
solidarity between Generations
we have always believed that our
children should not pay the price
for our actions
but only recently have we understood the
full meaning of these words
they mean that we must stop harming our
planet to preserve it for our children
and grandchildren
and two years ago
Europe became the first continent
to turn this commitment
into a climate law
this means
that climate neutrality in Europe by
2050 is now a legally binding Target
that can be enforced by our Union and in
court
we are putting
the full force of the law
at the service of our planet
[Applause]
this is the role of the European
commission as the guardian of our
treaties
we strive to stay true to the higher
values that our Union is built upon
and we ensure that our values apply to
all Europeans men and women
young and old of all colors of all
sexual orientations
of all faith
and none
but we are not alone in this task
it is a responsibility that we all share
we shared with people like you
the judges the lawyers the academics
but also the activists the human rights
Defenders the consumer associations
and all the ordinary citizens who bring
the law to life
you are the ones making sure that
everyone's rights are truly equal
that our children are safe online
and that our climate protection laws are
fully enforced
you are the backbone of our democracies
you are the backbone of our rule of law
it is thanks to you that the solemn
words
written years or decades ago in our
Charters treaties and constitutions
turn into reality every single day
and this is the beauty of democracy
it is a great
ever unfinished Symphony
and it is up to every new generation and
each one of us
to keep the music going
and this is also the beauty of our
European Union
we are the children of great jurists
from kikaru to Montesquieu
We Are The Heirs of the post-war
generation
who built peace through the rule of law
but the best part of our history
is still to be written
the path towards a more perfect union
has only just begun
thank you so much again for the
prestigious prize Long Live Europe thank
you
thank you
[Applause]
congratulations Excellency ladies and
gentlemen it is now my high privilege to
call to the podium his majesty King
Felipe the sixth world peace and Justice
awardee of 2019. your majesty
[Applause]
good morning everyone
a true honor to speak to this
distinguished audience allow me to
recognize some of you present
president
constitutional president of Ecuador and
first lady petition
prime minister of Canada
president and members of the world world
jurist Association and World law
Congress
vice president Vivian reading of the
world law Foundation
authorities panelists participants in
this New York 2023 were law Congress
ladies and gentlemen allow me to also
recognize the presence
of the president of the Supreme Court of
Justice of the Dominican Republic
and
two former three former presidents
of Mexico
Colombia Yuan Duke
Mr Levitz
it's an honor to see you
and a pleasure as well
and my fellow OD Andrew Young Ambassador
young I had the pleasure of seeing him
in Madrid recently and presenting him
the award and it was a great pleasure as
well
it'd be tough to follow the sequence
today so many beautiful and important
words have been spoken
allow me to add a few more
a few months ago on the 8th of May I
presided over the Madrid opening session
of this world law Congress 2023.
so to be here with you on this special
occasion at this closing ceremony is of
course an honor but also gives me
great personal satisfaction
an honor that is multiplied by the
significance of this event
at which we have just presented the
world peace and Liberty award to the
European commission represented by its
president usura ponderland
so allow me first
to offer her my sincere congratulations
on this award which without a question
recognizes
the most significant project of
multinational integration in our recent
history
from the outset it was above all
a political and legal project aimed at
consolidating peace and democracy in the
countries of the continent after World
War II
I would also like to extend my
congratulations to the recipients today
of the world Jewish Association Medals
of Honor presented later on in this
ceremony
among them are extraordinary jewists
from all over the world
as well as companies that have
demonstrated the extraordinary
commitment to the rule of law
a commitment shared by all of us here
today
so as I was saying this in the closing
ceremony of the 28th World Congress
has taken more than two years of
considerable effort to organize and has
succeeded in bringing more than one
thousand jurists from 70 different
countries
the results of the many discussions in
different panels will be of the utmost
interest and value to legislators
Regulators judges jurists and leaders
from all over the world
it is no coincidence that for this
ceremony we have gathered
at this un headquarters of New York
which of these times of profound
transformation in almost all areas of
Our Lives is called upon to perform an
indispensable role in resolving
conflicts and working for world peace
and cooperation
without question it is a pivotal
structure of an international
architecture founded upon strong and
effective multilateral institutions and
a law-based international order
this is an idea that the U.N Secretary
General has always championed as I
mentioned some months ago when he
received the Charles V award European
award in the late Emperor's retirement
site the monastery of just there in
catharis we thank secretary secretary
guterres for his generous Hospitality
today
ladies and gentlemen
it is truly a pleasure to be here again
at the UN headquarters a place where
as I mentioned in the younger of 2016
we must ensure the future of our planet
on this occasion as I addressed the
world world law Congress
I would like to pay tribute to two
jurists from the U.S
who together with Sir Winston Churchill
set out to mobilize the international
legal community in order to promote the
rule of law over the rule of Might
to this purpose they founded the world
Jewish Association
the legacy of these two men Charles Ryan
and Earl Warren must be preserved and
handed down to Future Generations
the Bar Association of the District of
Columbia elected Charles Ryan as its
president in 1955 after he ran on a
single pledge
to integrate the Bar Association
at this same moment in his life he
struck a friendship with Earl Warren
recently named President of the U.S
Supreme Court
they discussed the need to undertake a
global campaign to promote the rule of
law as the only alternative to
authoritarianism
this has remained the purpose and
mission of the world Juris Association
to this day
that friendship between those two men
led to the peace through law program
which has since been renamed the world
Jewish Association the oldest indeed the
only International Association bringing
together all branches of the law judges
lawyers professors and other members of
the legal profession at a global level
becoming a kind of international voice
of the law
the first word law Congress as you
mentioned before was held in Athens in
1963.
actually when Greece was still under the
reign of my grandfather King Paul the
first
and it was around this time too that
this award was established to
acknowledge and Express gratitude to
those International figures who through
their outstanding efforts have come to
symbolize a promotion and defense of the
rule of law
ladies and gentlemen today we're here to
pay tribute to the European Commission
Madam president thank you for doing us
the honor of being here to personally
accept this prize on behalf of the
institution you lead
the European commission and its
immediate predecessor the high authority
of the European coal and Steel Community
is still probably one of the most unique
elements of the European Union's
institutional architecture
and probably also one of the reasons
that explains its remarkable success
since the Treaty of Paris of 1951.
it acts as an institution that
represents the European Union's general
interests making sure that all member
states and all parts of the European
union benefit from our Union
and it plays a key role of course in the
European's political process through its
right of initiative in the legislative
process
it also acts as a guardian of the
treaties making sure that all member
states and economic actors respect the
European law
including its fundamental democratic
values as well as the rules that make up
our single Market
today these duties have become more
important than ever before
ladies and gentlemen it has been roughly
one year and a half
since the Russian aggression against
Ukraine started
since then we have witnessed the return
of War to the continent with a massive
loss of human lives millions of refugees
pouring out into safety and the level of
Destruction it brings us to memory what
most of us only knew from history books
documentaries or movies
we have seen how the pillars and which
we have built our European model for
decades have been seriously challenged
today we witnessed a clash between two
visions of the world
to make it simple one of force and
repression of intolerance and exclusion
the other
the European model
based on the values held in Article 2 of
the European Union treaty such as
democracy human dignity Freedom equality
the rule of law and the respect for
human rights
values that are the foundation of the
European construction that are part of
the identity of the Union as a political
community
and that on such an occasion as today's
remind us of Jean Monet and Robert
Schumann the founding fathers of an
ambitious and hopeful project the
current European Union whose
construction began three-quarters of a
century ago
and normal than ever
we still need to fight for the European
Union as we know it
we need people to lead us and
continuously
Revitalize our trust and our hope in it
now more than ever we need the European
Union to be a force of good
in the world defending Liberty
sovereignty and territorial Integrity of
States also defending a rules-based
order in line with the U.N Charter
Madam president you are at the helm of
an institution the European commission
that has been key to ensure Europe's
peace and prosperity for almost 70 years
like your predecessors you have faced
the different crises and challenges by
advocating European Solutions
and by doing so you have contributed to
strengthening Europe and pushing pushing
European integration to new levels
in these paralyzed times in which we all
live
the the union needs a strong Commission
one that acts as a Dependable guardian
of the treaties and that keeps up the
legislative and political momentum of
the reform agenda
at a time when our institutions and
Norms are being increasingly challenged
and even questioned
the European commission has shown the
value of moderation centrality and
constraint as key traits of doing
politics bringing together all member
states in the council
now presided by Spain for the next six
months
and all political groupings around the
European Parliament
and in this regard we must not forget
that the advances made in building the
European project
have responded democratically to the
will of our citizens who have largely
agreed to strengthen and enlarge the
Union
this is a process in which our national
parliaments have also of course played a
decisive role embracing plurality
respecting difference seeking the middle
ground in order to move forward adopting
debate and consensus as tools of
progress
these actions and attitudes are at the
very heart of democracy and essential to
preserve it
because as Europeans president from the
Lion
I think we clearly share the belief that
democracy is today the soul of Europe
Madam President we thank you once again
and congratulate you for this award
that recognizes the important role
played by European Commission in
safeguarding the European project as one
of principles and values rights and
freedoms prosperity and peace
you know you can always count on Spain
in working towards this objective
because these times the demand greater
Unity
and that is how we have responded and
will continue to do so within the
European framework
we will have to keep maintaining Unity
both within Europe and together with our
key Partners allies and Friends
supporting Ukraine and in upholding the
international order
in this task it is important to count on
our allies on the European friends and
of course countries like this one the
hosts of the United States and all those
like-minded Partners countries and
regions many of them represented here
with whom we share values and principles
and to conclude
and with Spain as I mentioned currently
holding the presidency of the European
Council of the European Union
I would like to recall the words of one
of our most eminent thinkers said
who reflecting upon Spain's difficulties
almost a century ago
he asserted that Europe
often bring a problem was actually the
solution
these words remain true today not only
for Spain but for all our member states
and future member states
so let us continue to believe in the
power of the great hope that Europe
represents in a project worthy of our
trust and our efforts for the good of
all but for the good of our countries in
our societies congratulations again
Madam president and many thanks to you
all
thank you
thank you your majesty ladies and
gentlemen we're going to pause our
proceedings for five minutes as some of
our dignitaries must depart for security
reasons I ask that you remain in your
seats thank you